How does a clown put on a face?
Where does she start?
First, she puts on white face paint.
What comes next?
How does a clown put on a face?
Next, she puts paint around her mouth.
She paints a big, red smile.
What is next?
How does a clown put on her face?
Next, she paints her eyelids.
What does she put on next?
How does a clown put on her face?
Next, she puts on big, fuzzy eyebrows.
What comes after that?
Then she paints big, pink circles on her cheeks.
What comes next?
How does a clown put on her face?
Next, she puts on her red nose.
It honks if you squeeze it.
What does she do next?
How does a clown put on her face?
After putting on a red nose, she puts on a silly wig.
What does she do next?
Then she gets dressed.
She puts on a polka-dot jacket and striped pants.
And she puts on big, floppy shoes.
At last, the clown leaves the dressing room.
Now, it's time to make kids laugh.